hi everyone i'm erica chong a customer
engineer at google cloud welcome back to
google cloud technical guides for
startups a video series designed for
startup technical enablement to help
startups to start build and grow their
businesses successfully and sustainably
on google cloud
this episode focuses on how you can make
the most of google cloud through various
startup offers
in this video we're going to cover
google for startups program for startups
from pre-c to series a what the program
entails eligibility requirements and
best practices
the migration incentive program for
startups post series a on another cloud
platform
and best practices and resources for
your startup so without any further ado
let's get right into exploring the
benefits and resources of google for
startups cloud program together our
current program supports your startups
growth with google for startups cloud
program
investor back startups get financial
technical and business support that
scales with them they'll build with
intelligent cost-effective proven
technology that can enable startups to
move fast
as part of the program they can upskill
their team on the technical support side
our startup success team is in place as
a dedicated resource to connect with
program members to ensure that they have
the technical support they need to
successfully build their businesses
this program features access to our
customer engineers to help with
architectural reviews troubleshooting
and even invitations to technical
training and certification programs as
well as support and documentation they
can also get a financial boost
startups that are accepted into the
program will get their first year with
google cloud covered up to a total of
one hundred thousand dollars usd
in year two they'll get twenty percent
of google cloud usage covered also up to
one hundred thousand dollars usd
this program is designed to help
startups to get off the ground when they
may need it the most and then on to a
sustainable growth path for the future
we also see a lot of startups using
credits to test new features or try out
products such as looker or firebase
details and conditions can be found at
cloud.google.com
they can also receive business support
you'll get tailored support from our
startup success team and our sales teams
with a single point of contact to help
you navigate google
attend special events meet google
engineers and specialists and even
connect with startup peers solving
similar challenges in the google cloud
startup community
they may even be co-marketing
opportunities with startups that you can
be invited to to co-create a case study
or be featured in a blog post now that
we've gone over what the google for
startups cloud program is let's talk
about how to qualify for it all
customers must be funded with publicly
verifiable equity investments up to and
including pre-seed angel seed and series
n
if series a this must have been raised
within the past 12 months
they must also have been founded within
10 years of applying to the program and
have a publicly available company
website and a unique company email
domain
if you need to create a custom email
account sign up for google workspace
you must also have a valid google cloud
billing account id linked to the domain
and company email on your application
additionally a customer must not be
already enrolled in the google for
startups cloud program or have received
an excess of four thousand dollars usd
in google cloud credits
you must also not be a company who is
ipo'd or been acquired or an educational
institution government entity nonprofit
personal blog dev shop consultancy or
agency
you must also not be a crypto mining
company or a company distributing tokens
contrary to regulatory guidance in your
jurisdiction
for example companies issuing tokens
solely for speculative purposes will not
be considered
apply at
cloud.google.com forward slash startup
and accept the program terms and
conditions your application will be
rooted for review to ensure we can
validate your identity and confirm
eligibility
if accepted credits are activated in the
billing account provided in the
application and an email notification is
sent to the applicant with an overview
of the program
if we cannot accept your application an
email notification is sent to the
applicant with more information and
guidance on how to remedy the issues
google for startups cloud credits carry
the same scope as most other cloud
credit programs in 2022 they can be used
for google cloud services like bigquery
and cloud run it can also be used for
other offerings such as looker and
activio
in addition these credits can be used
for firebase and support services check
out the links in the description box
below for more details
google for service cloud credits will
not cover the cost of third-party
marketplace licenses
workspace maps and quick labs benefits
are managed separately and can be
redeemed by eligible startups by
emailing cloudstartupsupport google.com
let's go over some best practices for
your application verifying your identity
is the first step to applying for google
for startups cloud program this process
helps us to protect you and your company
and ensure the correct startups are
enrolling in the program
here are some pro tips to help us do
this step quickly and efficiently
apply with your startup's business email
address not a personal one for example
use app coolstartup.com not coolstartup
gmail.com
ensure your email address and business
domain on the application matches
next provide an active google cloud
billing id example on the screen
make sure that you have an individual
google cloud billing id that is just for
your singular company
while we're on the subject of billing
ids use a billing id that your company
controls the owner of the billing
account must have the same email domain
as the email and domain used on the
application
check your startup's funding your
startup must have received pre-c to
series a equity funding and if series a
that funding must have occurred within
one year of applying to that program
provide documentation of equity
investments via publicly available
online sources
examples include reputable news articles
investment aggregator sites and
investment portfolio posts
we cannot accept confidential
information and or social media posts
from your own company
please remember to double check all
parts of the application and eligibility
requirements prior to submitting and
with that you're ready to go
if your startup is beyond series a and
looking to migrate across from another
cloud provider or on-prem system this
migration program is the program for you
our migration incentive program is
designed to support later stage startups
by offsetting costs of migrating cloud
services and infrastructure to google
cloud
startups will receive high-touch
technical support to both plan and
execute the migration and access to
instructor-led and online training to
help ensure your team has the required
technical capabilities
our google cloud engineers and ecosystem
partners are ready to support you and
your migration journey
other benefits such as google workspace
google maps and google cloud skills
boost benefits are also offered to these
startups and your account manager will
support you in benefiting from these
incentives and beyond
to learn more about the migration
incentive program
please reach out to your dedicated sales
team who could be your personal guide
throughout the entire process you can be
connected to your sales team at
cloud.google.com
forward slash contact
apply for the google for startups cloud
program today
for google cloud technical support such
as bugs or quota requests or google
cloud billing support such as invoices
and account administration sign up for a
support plan at cloud.google.com forward
slash support this support will allow
you to self-service file tickets from
within your google cloud console
also be sure to check out the startup
resource homepage link in the
description box below a couple of
resources have been added to the
description box below to help you
understand these programs in further
detail so be sure to check them out in
the next episode we'll cover cloud
firestore and datastore including sample
architecture and a demonstration of
building a web application powered by
firestore
that brings us to the end of this video
where we went over the google for
startups program and the migration
incentive program
stay tuned for all the exciting and
helpful content that we have for you and
don't forget to like and subscribe to
our youtube channel click on the bell
icon to be notified each time a new
video is posted we hope to see you soon
in our next video
[Music]